elle était présente à Mani Lamo lors du
Téléton justement Valérie PCR la députée
de la 2e circonscription des Yvelines
est aussi la responsable de l'UMP dans
le département seulement maintenant elle
siège au côté de François Fillon en tant
que rassemblement pour l'UMP le rump
c'est même la seule députée desivelin à
avoir rejoint ce groupe parlementaire
elle va nous donner ses explications et
puis elle a aussi évoqué avec nous la
question des municipales am Mani lesam
la ville est détenue par les socialistes
pour l'instant soyez patient d'abord
avant d'avoir des têtes de Liss il faut
avoir des projets alors faut qu'on fasse
des proj
un petit mot juste sur la situation de
l'UMP aujourd'hui où siègez-vous à
l'Assemblée nationale alors je siège au
groupe rassemblement P qui appelle
aujourd'hui à un revote aux élections
aux élections de l'UMP parce que nous
voulons avoir nous avons un problème
démocratique aujourd'hui et à problème
démocratique solution démocratique c'est
pour ça avec les non alignés avec un
certain nombre de partisans de François
Fillon et Jean-François Copé nous
appelons aujourd'hui à un nouveau vote à
l'UMP